so i'm gonna show you a clip right now
uh of tom holland going on late night
with seth meyers uh talking about
some costume upgrades for one of the
spiderman i'll give you a spoiler and
i'm not gonna tell you who but one of us
has a fake ass in their suit really
try to find the fake ass i remember
being on set being like wow
oh hang on a minute nah that's not real
right
look this isn't my normal content but
let me tell you that it's fun to
speculate who has a fake one uh i don't
think it's tom holland just because
um i mean he's the youngest and i mean
we've seen this dude he does work out i
kind of want to say it's toby maguire
i don't know about you guys but it's
definitely a higher possibility because
he's older and probably doesn't work out
as much
uh but i mean
i don't want to uh i don't want to shame
anyone uh the funny part is that there
was probably a ton of meetings about
this
and they were staring at a bunch of
pictures of of this one spider-man's
butt and had to make the decision on
whether or not they should
put some extra padding in there and
that's hilarious
and that's hollywood for you um you got
to make sure that you keep that
signature spider-man look but anyways in
the comments do me a favor let me know
who you think has a fake one
um i it's hard to get pictures of
the movie itself or at least clear ones
because i mean there is no official
release yet i think it's not coming till
uh the late march
but i mean this is your lighthearted
news for today so
uh tell me in the comments uh i'll see
you guys tomorrow
don't forget to subscribe i am doing
this every day thanks guys